since the very beginning of time,
we've been trying to recreate what
nature put in front of our eyes
nature seems to hold some kind of secret that
makes it both beautiful and resilient and we've
been obsessed with trying to replicate that
ability after thousands of years we've been
pretty successful in creating our own version of
the world but this is the first time in history
that we've actually had the technology to really
extract the secrets of Nature and replicate some
of its very elegant designs I'm sure you've
noticed more and more buildings popping up
that are inspired by nature but similar to what
we're seeing with AI right now just because we
can doesn't mean we should so copying nature
is it fundamentally flawed does nature really
have the answer to a better future does
it even make sense to scale these designs
portion of this video is sponsored by AG1
I'm not a religious person but I had
something very close to a spiritual
experience when I first visited Sagrada
Familia suddenly I was floating in this
strange Forest built out of bones or sand
crafted with such detail and a ceiling
that reminded me of the sky the forest the
sun and the universe all at the same time
Gaudi was obsessed with nature and for him it
was the ultimate source of inspiration he would
study ants tree snakes skeletons and when he was
commissioned as big projects to Sagrada Familia
the place of God he tried to extract those lessons
and recreate them in his building so if you go in
this building most people will probably say that
it feels organic but there's actually a logical
reason for this feeling he realized nature
had a series of geometric rules the hyperbolic
paraboloid the conoid a double turn helicoidal
shape creating a structure now known as a fractal
but he's probably best known for his extensive use
of catenary arches which is formed when a chain of
uniform density is hung from two points creating
a shape that's in complete tension when you
inverse this you get a shape that's in complete
compression you could probably call his designs an
early form of biomimicry which is defined as the
design and production of materials structures and
systems that are modeled on biological entities
and processes but when Gaudi started the project
in 1882 they didn't really have parametric
software and in fact they didn't even have
computers so he constructed models using way to
change then he would either place a mirror or take
photographs and flip it upside down to understand
the structure of the building the problem is that
this project is uh never finished it's been going
on for more than a hundred years and it's supposed
to finally finish in 2026 and I think that's
the problem with buildings inspired by Nature
even though they can be incredibly beautiful
compared to a standard boxy building they can be
extremely hard to build and it can consume a lot
of resources alright let's look at another example
this is a Venus Flower Basket sea sponge it looks
very delicate but it's got a very strong lattice
structure that provides stiffness while being
able to bend at the intersections meaning it
can Flex without damaging the core Arrangement the
rounded shape disperses the forces from the strong
currents and this mesh forms a hollow basket
that allows water and nutrition to filter through
you've probably seen this building before it's
the iconic building in the London Skyline known
as the Gherkin which is probably a more catchy
name than the Venus Flower Basket sea sponge
but this building mimics the shape and structure
of the sponge and basically does the same thing
but in air the rounded shape allows the air to
flow smoothly around the building which creates
pressure differences that power the natural
ventilation system so it's not only mimicking
the form but it's also mimicking the function
and performance of the organism the system guides
fresh air into atriums at every six stories which
is distributed to each floor through its double
facade this double skin facade also provides extra
insulation in the winters and this entire system
reduces the power consumption of the building by
50 percent or that's what it was supposed to be
in 2005 one of the operable Windows broke off
the facade and they decided to limit the use
of this passive ventilation system and now it just
operates on a very standard mechanical ventilation
system just like any other building actually when
we were doing research for this video we could
only find a handful of truly successful
examples that really seem to emulate the
design and principles of nature even the watercube
building in Beijing inspired by soap bubbles which
received lead gold has a 30 reduction in energy
consumption compared to similar buildings to build
this it used 90 kilometers of Steel it's a hundred
thousand square meters of plastic it's not really
the most sustainable material this really makes me
wonder is it practical to scale Nature's designs
I've been following these guys since
I was in architecture school every
year the research group at itke built
these biomimic every year the research
group at biometric started the research
group at itke built these biomimic biomip
foreign
you're feeling so tired that you can't even say
basic words ag1 is my go-to what I'm feeling a
little bit groggy a little bit tired and it
really helps me with my stress and focus I
started taking ag1 during the pandemic basically
when I realized I needed to start taking a little
bit more accountability for my health and it was
long before I was getting paid to talk about it
it's a foundational nutritional supplement
so it also supports immune Health gut health
with 75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients I do try to eat nutrient-dense meals
but it's not always realistic ag1 is easy to drink
it tastes good so it's really easy to incorporate
into your routine and I always take it when I'm
traveling just so that I know I've covered all
my bases when it comes to my nutrition go to
drinkaj1.com damily to get started on your very
first order ag1 is going to give my community
a free one-year supply of AG vitamin D3 and
MK2 and 5 ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase thanks aguan for sponsoring this video
okay as I was saying the research group at itke
built these biomimetic Pavilions every year not
using standard materials like concrete and steel
but new high performing materials this was their
first Pavilion in 2010 where they explore the
structural capacities and the elastic bending
behavior of birch plywood strips they input
the material properties into a digital model
and once they come up with an ideal form
they used a six axis robot to manufacture
the pieces which they assembled manually on
site similarly in 2011 they used a digital
model to simulate the material behavior and
form they use a robotic arm to manufacture
the pieces which then they manually assembled
on site in 2012 see what a big leap that is
from this to this this design was based off their
analysis of a lobster's exoskeleton and this year
The Pavilion was entirely robotically
fabricated this is from the team
so what they're trying to say is they couldn't
just replicate the structural Arrangement at
an abstract level using any material because
this type of structure would only work with a
unique material properties of the biological role
model in this case the chicken fibers found in
the lobsters so they had to find a material
with similar properties in this case carbon
and glass fiber Composites and because this
material had never been used this way before
they had to think of a new way of using it bye
again inputting the material properties into a
digital model and simulating a structure
that would optimize the capabilities of
this material all of this led to a really cool
ass looking form as well as an extremely high
performing structure only four millimeters
of opposite laminate while spanning 8 meters
2013 was the first time they used microcomputer
tomography in their process which gave them the
ability to analyze this time a beetle Shell at
a very intricate level from this they discovered
that the shawl is a double layer structure
connected by curve support elements kind of
like a column the fiber layout within this
column which is called the trabecula merges
the upper and lower shawl segments based on
this they also developed a double layered
modular system again using carbon and glass
fiber Composites and basically they weaved it
together using another new method two mirin Kuka
robots a slave robot and a master robot foreign
so what I'm trying to show you here is with
every new technology that's introduced into
the system they're able to more closely
mimic Nature's designs and they're able
to better optimize the characteristics of each
material leading to stronger and more resource
efficient structures that don't really look
like anything else that's been built before
just last year they introduced a new challenge
into the mix a Sustainable Building Material
flax fibers the renewable and biodegradable
and they're comparable and their structural
properties as the glass and carbon fiber
but they have a much lower embodied energy
taking this idea one step further this is
a five meter tall structure by Nary oxman
Studio made entirely of cells of living
organisms AKA biopolymers it's made of
80 water 20 trees Apple skins and shrimp cells
which are some of the most common biopolymers
on our planet here they 3D print the material
into a layered structure that combines elements
that are like shells and also like skins
creating a kind of Bio composite the idea
is that over its lifespan the structure
reacts to the environment changing in
shape or color or rigidity depending on
the temperature or humidity or sunlight
I don't know how we could scale the size
of a building per se but biopolymers do
have really great insulation properties and
they can regulate moisture as well and the
point here is that these biocompositions
can be specifically combined and tuned to
the kind of behavior that you're looking
for imagine we could build buildings or
Towers or even cities as living organisms
that adapt and respond to their environment
and at the end of the building's life
cycle it just decomposes into the Earth
but what if we didn't design at all and instead
of mimicking nature we just let nature design
in the silk Pavilion project by by Nary oxman
and our team they co-created a six meter tall
fiber structure with silkworms they found
that the silkworms distribute themselves
based on the environmental conditions like
gravity heat and light so in order to control
the density of the silkworms in turn the
density of the fabric they've designed a
robotic Gloom which would rotate in order
to control these environmental conditions
the primary structure was a kind of scaffolding
made of soluble knit which provided a template
that the silkworms could follow so going Beyond
just sustainability or optimizing the material
properties this new way of co-creating with
other species and designing the process not
just the final form it gives each structure
its own kind of expression kind of a soul
I find it kind of comforting that in nature
there's logic and reason behind every single
shape every single curvature every single hair
there's a seamless connection between function
and form which lead to designs that make the
most optimal use of resources and that's probably
because Nature has been developing and iterating
through these designs for like 3.8 billion years
dumping the bad ones and letting the Smart Ones
continue on the smartest part of nature is that
it's a closed-loop system where the death of
one organism means the nutrients for another
where different species can coexist and thrive in
a symbiotic relationship sometimes totally weird
relationships remember the Venus Flower Basket
sea sponge this creature has a very interesting
relationship with a particular type of deep sea
shrimp when a young shrimp meets his partner
they take shelter in the sponge which protects it
from predators the skeletal framework as we talked
about before it allows the nutrients to filter
through and this feeds the shrimp in return the
shrimp cleaned the inside of the sponge but once
this shrimp couple grows older they become too
big to fit through the mesh and they're trapped in
there until they die their offspring however are
small enough to fit through so they can leave
to find their own partners and also their own
Flower Basket that's nature it's a beautiful and
smart system but it's a system of give and take
we've just been taking and taking and
taking for so long using the Earth as
our playground that I think we've completely
forgotten that we're a part of this system and
one day in a not so distant future
we're also gonna have to give back
thanks for watching guys if you guys are
interested in all the research that didn't
make it into this video you can find our
research booklet down in the description
also I have a Discord server and
a newsletter I'll leave those in
the description as well and with that
I'll see you guys in the next video
thank you